the other side of it is that you can go
full time fairly quickly depending on
the niche or business you are in if you
go into youtube having a product to sell
whether physical or digital product you
can monetize really quickly and become
full-time really quickly i know real
estate agents that
do coaching and consulting and things
like that have very small youtube
channels like 10 000 or less and they
are killing it financially because of
the model in which they have their
youtube channel helping their business
so i just think it's it's accepting that
it doesn't have to look like the
millions you can just build your own
path in it because it is unconventional
welcome to the think media podcast my
name is heather torres and i'm your host
here of this show where we help you
build your influence on youtube and then
turn that influence into a high impact
and a high profit online business today
i am so excited because i am joined by
one of our think media family members
omar l tacory in today's video we're
going to be walking through what it took
to become a full-time youtuber and
five secrets that omar has learned over
his journey of becoming a youtuber now
if you've not met omar over on our think
media channel he's actually been
creating video not just with think media
but for the last 15 years he's helped
think media grow to over 2 million
subscribers and has accumulated over 23
million views on videos he's created for
the channel every day his content is
reaching thousands of people with the
purpose of helping them get better with
video omar's influenced product
development for major brands like sony
canon and adobe he's also helped dozens
of industry-leading experts launch their
video podcast and is an expert in the
space let's get into today's featured
conversation with omar eltakori
[Music]
okay i am beyond excited because this
day is finally here omar i've wanted to
have you on the podcast for a few years
now we finally made it happen and i'm
excited to bring you to the think media
fam man i'm pumped to be a part of the
think media fam in so many ways but
excited to actually sit down and talk
about a little a couple of things that
i've learned over the last few years yes
and we're gonna dive into um some of the
secrets to becoming a full-time youtuber
you've been a full-time youtuber for a
few years now but i'd like to take the
story back you know uh young omar and
really how you even got into video and
how you got into youtube in general yeah
i mean it all started in high school i
took an elective as most people get an
option to and i took uh broadcast
journalism and it's the people that make
the morning announcements and i always
thought it was so cool because like
second period rolls around and you watch
people on screen and they make fun
commercials and things like that and so
when i took that i i just fell in love
with the process of creating videos and
the creativity behind making videos and
so i ended up going to target getting
like what is called like a usb flip at
the time it had a pop-out usb that you
could plug in your computer to transfer
footage but i started vlogging
downloaded sony vegas uh illegally uh
because i was just in high school
couldn't afford it but started making
videos and then you know some of my
friends started making music then i
started making music videos and a long
story short here i am like almost 15
years later and i'm now teaching all
this stuff so it's really i find myself
really in a cool position um to be able
to teach the things that i've learned
over the course of the years but that's
kind of how it started and then you know
as far as like when me and sean got
connected this was like 2016. sean was
doing youtube kind of by himself
shooting editing and all that stuff and
that's when he connected with you and he
wanted to put together a course with you
uh
video ranking academy and this is when
we ran into each other at the gym
he said let's go grab coffee i need help
and at the time i was kind of doing
freelance work and that the rest is kind
of history that was 2016. i think the
channel was at around 70 000 subs at the
time
and um and yeah it's been crazy and then
you know fast forward to i think around
2019 would be the first time where he
put me on the channel like i left from
being behind the camera getting in front
of the camera and we did a collab on a
couple videos and then uh
surely but surely uh
slowly but surely uh you know started
making videos by myself and here we are
later
you know post
all the crazy things where we got
full-time creators and i'm probably
close to 200 videos in um and so i've
learned a lot in the process
kind of went full-time on in front of
the camera at around 700 000 subs and we
just recently passed 2 million and so
it's been a journey and it's been really
cool but i'm excited to share these
secrets it makes me so excited to have
you on because i've seen your journey
i've seen you grow into becoming a
full-time youtuber from behind the
camera to in front of the camera and
you're right there's there are some
lessons that you um that you learned
throughout that the first one really is
learn the language of video and i want
you to go deeper into that because i
think that as people come into this
space um they think it's just like a
cash machine right like bing it's all
gonna work um but what does it mean to
learn the language of video i think uh
it encompasses so much but i think one
way i kind of try to make it similarly
communicated is that i i think video
creation is a new form of language uh
2010 they stopped teaching cursive or
they gave teachers the option to stop
teaching it and i believe like the
world's newest way of communication is
through video and when i when i think
about video being a language i think of
it in the sense of like you
understanding the general gist of what
it entails to create a video what is
audio what is lighting a little bit
about editing just a little bit because
i'm finding that most people uh that
want to just pay their way to success
they they're wanting other people to
think for them in that regard but you
you're you're robbing yourself from the
ability to speak into uh what you are
building and uh and so i see it like you
know if you go on like a vacation and
you had a translator with you it'd be
kind of frustrated or frustrating to
make your way along the land but if you
knew the language a little bit and can
get by and buy you know make a couple
purchases here and there you can find
your way through the towns better and so
i would say it like just uh giving the
time of investment to learn the video
game i guess you could say and uh just
this and i think there is a level of
just enough in this regard like knowing
what it is to be in focus and what it
what it takes to have a back a blurry
background and
knowing what you know kind of setup you
need to go for for the type of content
you want to produce i just think that
committing to learning video as a
language is uh is key and so uh that
might just be buying a camera just to
learn it going on think media and
watching a tutorial um that might be
getting some video clips and and trying
to edit it yourself and learning how to
add a title and so that you know that
it's called put a title on that video
when you're correcting your future
editor um so i i just think it'll help
you communicate what you're trying to do
over time when you learn video and so
that's what think media is for that's
kind of like why we exist is so that
people who know nothing about video can
get started when it comes to either
editing just using your smartphone
wanting to start live streaming starting
a video podcast like this we want to
help you
learn those things and that's who i'm
thinking about when i'm creating this
content yeah i love so much when you
talk about even just like the language
of video um
even over the years as you know we've
seen video platforms come and go vine
and now now we've tick-tock and now
youtube has shorts and then long form
video and then video podcasts like um
the language is also changing too so
it's staying up to date with that and i
think you know number two would be
becoming a youtube connoisseur and
really understanding the game of youtube
because what's incredible is that this
is one of the fastest growing small
business types youtube alone has over
400 000 full-time content creators
happening and that's just starting like
we're just at the beginning of this and
so for you to really speak into what
does it mean to become a youtube
connoisseur and understand this platform
specifically yeah i i think
it's kind of hard to win
at a sport if you don't know how to play
it you know i picked up golf
and i learned that there's two ways of
learning golf number one is like
actually playing the sport and the other
one of it is the etiquette like you
could play with a group of people and if
you have the wrong etiquette they will
not want to play with you i think
learning like the etiquette of youtube
why things work on youtube and what i
mean by being a youtube connoisseur like
do you even enjoy watching youtube
videos or do you see it as a cash grab i
mean i i genuinely enjoy at the end of
my day going on my youtube tv i put my
money where my mouth is i pay for
youtube tv and uh or youtube red
and we i just i don't know
i i watch youtube videos i just love
youtube i love that like everyday people
can create amazing content but also you
can get the high level stuff from like
whatever people you want to follow or
subscribe to but i think there's just so
much when it comes to consuming uh
youtube videos you're learning you're
absorbing and and then it allows you to
kind of like process and how you can
communicate that in your own way and
when you're creating your videos or
trying to communicate to your audience
and maybe hop on a trend or something
like just simply being on youtube uh and
consuming it can give you so many video
ideas you know there's this guy right
now who's kind of like the new golden
child of youtube his name's ryan trahan
he's literally taking over youtube i
would say if you are listening to this
video podcast and you want to be a
full-time youtuber and you don't know
who ryan trahan is right now you need to
fall in love with the game of youtube or
become a youtube connoisseur and so uh i
just think it it only helps um it's it's
hard to to be an expert in something if
you don't even know understand how it's
even happening and so you know adjusting
fire knowing that shorts are getting a
lot of love so like what does that mean
for your channel uh and and learning the
things along the lines of uh what is
working for other people and how other
industries and niches are creating
videos is just so helpful for you to
carry that on in your youtube journey
yeah and i i think also what i love
about becoming a youtube connoisseur as
a full-time youtuber is you do get to
kind of pick from the buffet of all
these different types of creators you
know there's creators who are just using
their smartphone creating great content
and then there's creators who are
building out massive studios and sets
and so it's pulling from those pieces
and figuring out what's going to work
for you and i think it helps with your
voice it does you know i i've taken on
communication at our church being able
to preach a couple weekends in the year
and my pastor told me that like you know
find three voices like and you should be
a culmination of those three with you in
it so it really becomes you i think in
the same way based off of your interests
and who you're subscribed to and the
type of videos you're attracted to all
that kind of plays a role on like the
type of creator you kind of want to be
and that that can actually influence you
in such a good way
this video was sponsored by stream yard
this is our go-to platform for live
streaming to youtube and facebook
especially when we have multiple people
joining us on a stream with an
incredibly easy to use interface for
doing cool transitions bringing in text
on the screen and seamlessly bringing on
guests this is the perfect platform for
the new and experienced creators alike
next is never forget who you're serving
as you become a full-time youtuber
it is i mean i'm sorry to tell you think
media podcast it is a job right like
becoming a full-time youtuber it's work
but never really forgetting who you're
serving right because as you grow um
that doesn't mean that your audience
necessarily is growing in that way go
deeper on that for me yeah i i i can see
how so many
youtubers who kind of just do the
traditional route and build an influence
on just like them and that's kind of it
uh they kind of just hit i believe like
a tipping point and sometimes it results
in like burnout but it also results in
like dude i'm kind of bored and you know
i'm over this person you know but i
think there's so there's so much wisdom
in realizing who you are constantly
trying to reach and i always like to say
this but like the person that i'm always
thinking of when i'm creating content in
the most healthy way possible is heather
torres you know she's a
mom who takes care of three kids and
they homeschool her her and her husband
and she's trying to learn the game of
video and learn the language and so uh
as the person who can speak it fluently
i want to always remember that she
doesn't always know the terminologies i
know she doesn't always know the the
insider language that i that i know
based off of the gear and the tech that
i'm talking about and so keeping her at
the forefront is really helping me
create videos but i can i've found
myself in certain uh seasons where i'm
like just on autopilot you know like
it's just i'm making the video just
because we got to crank out another
video you know but keeping the person
that i'm trying to help and i think we
always we we help or we encourage people
to always think about the person you are
still trying to reach you know maybe
you've reached a handful of them but
there's still more of those people that
you need to reach and
we always encourage that the biggest
group of people in any industry is the
beginner group of people the people just
getting into whatever the thing it is
that you are teaching and so there are
always new people coming into the game
of creating content and so i don't want
to lose that and so i i don't want you
to lose that don't lose your love for
the person that's just new uh we always
encourage repetition just be repetitive
don't get annoyed with yourself saying
the same thing over and over you gotta
just press record you gotta punch fear
in the face um but i i just think it's a
key element uh when creating videos
especially at the and just take it from
us at the level we're creating videos at
uploading upwards to ten videos a week
on think media uh and and i think media
podcast combined we are we are thinking
about the person we are serving uh first
and then we go start creating so so good
becoming a full-time youtuber a lot of
times can be lonely did you ever
experience being lonely becoming a
full-time youtuber and what advice do
you have to people who are wanting to
step into that um what should they be
looking for in building community yeah i
think like you mentioned about youtube
being like a small business like in
youtube in some sense if you're wanting
to become a full-time youtuber you are
going on the entrepreneur journey that's
a journey i have found is kind of lonely
you know when i first quit my job at a
church that i was working at and wanted
to pursue just my freelance work and
creative work you know i'm hitting up
people like hey you want to go grab
lunch like sorry man in a meeting like
hey how about tomorrow no i got this
thing going like dang dude i just want
to grab lunch with somebody like it does
get lonely yeah and and so finding
people you can connect with uh whether
it's in your niche or it's in or it's
with people who are doing the same thing
you're doing can be so beneficial to you
staying in it for the long haul uh this
isn't a sprint we say that youtube is a
marathon and if you wanna last you're
gonna need community to help you
encourage you when you run out of video
ideas or when you uploaded that video
and you accidentally said something that
might get you canceled or something you
know like i don't know but like you need
the encouragement and the community to
surround you and that's what we have at
so many different levels here at think
media we have it on a you know uh on an
organizational level with each other and
able to speak into each other and
encourage each other but also the
community communities we're creating for
other creators like with this podcast
like on think media or our vra students
or boot camp students like we just want
to create communities so people can
connect with other people that are in
the same journey so that they know that
they're not alone in doing this and that
you can bounce back ideas i think the
powerful thing about community is you
know the the idea of testing hey what do
you think about this thumbnail versus
this one this one's much better like and
we have we have a thumbnail thread but i
still like texting kyle just you know
this one or this one double tap heart
boom helpful i needed that you know i
needed to go to sleep tonight and so i
needed that uh affirmation kyle thank
you um but i i just think it's so
powerful to have that community to to
dial in certain titles maybe or even
talk through like how would your week
why didn't you upload that video you
said you were going to upload a video
how about accountability with your
community so i think if you want to be a
full-time creator
it's just kind of overlooked that you
got to do it all yourself but the
reality is you're going to need a
community yeah and talking about the
journey of even becoming a full-time
content creator a full-time youtuber
specifically um i think it's really
interesting we've had this conversation
before that to our kids your daughter my
kids this is quote unquote normal right
like what we do what mom and dad do what
you know
it's so funny actually seeing ruby talk
like she's on youtube or like she's like
hey papa can i take a thumbnail
yeah it's hilarious yeah um and so what
we're doing what we're building as a
full-time youtuber both of us uh is it's
unconventional right this journey is
unconventional and actually leaning into
that let's go deeper into
this journey is unconventional and
that's part of becoming a full-time
youtuber yeah i i think the idea of
being a full-time youtube youtuber being
unconventional in nature
is something you just need to accept
because you know you set a stat like how
many youtube creators are full-time yeah
over 400 000. i actually think that's
dirty data yeah because there are people
behind that 400 000 creating content
editing videos strategically planning
coming up with video ideas like we have
full-time youtubers at think media i
think around about 20 plus full-time
youtubers because we all work for a
channel called think media so i think
the the nature can go so widespread uh
that is one one angle of it one angle of
it is that you can be a full-time
youtuber like i was with sean not being
in front of the camera but being behind
the camera i would consider you a
full-time youtuber you're developing the
skills you're learning the culture of
youtube you're consuming the content
dude you are a youtuber or dudette
the other side of it is that you can go
full time fairly quickly depending on
the niche or business you are in if you
go into youtube having a product to sell
whether physical or digital product you
can monetize really quickly and become
full-time really quickly uh you know
maybe you're a real estate agent i know
real estate agents that uh do coaching
and consulting and things like that have
very small youtube channels like 10 000
or less and they are killing it
financially because of the model in
which they have their youtube channel
helping their business so i just think
it's it's accepting that it doesn't have
to look like the millions it doesn't
have to look like uh what's traditional
youtubey you know like and uh
and that you can just build your own
path in it because it is unconventional
you know the i mentioned that kid ryan
trahan doing something that we've never
seen before
well he's doing something unconventional
we've never seen this before what's
going to come from this we're going to
see a lot of things coming from people
learning from what he's doing and doing
it until there's just another
ryan or whoever the next person is doing
something again unconventional so i
would i would go so far to say youtube
rewards unconventionalism
you know if you can figure out a way to
reach your audience in a new fresh way
uh that's another angle to it but i just
think the idea and the secret being that
like you need to accept the reality that
you being a full-time youtuber is not
necessarily normal yeah okay i'm
throwing this uh wild card at you here
we go what do you love about being a
full-time youtuber
oh man uh i would say maybe the first
thing that comes to mind uh in regards
to what i love about being a full-time
youtuber is when i get to meet the
people in person when i catch them at a
convention or a conference and they tell
me how helpful the videos are i'm in the
comments like crazy i understand that
making these videos are helping a ton of
people but it's one that when the people
share their story real quick whether you
know how how it's helped them go from
this place to that place it really does
make me
encourage to keep making videos back to
community you know i need the human
connection still even though you know we
are connected in some capacity online
and all that stuff but um
it's funny because
there can go weeks where i don't leave
if like a five mile radius you know like
kyle anderson studios is maybe a seven
minute drive from my house and uh that's
where we record just people know yeah
this is where we record not really a
studio actually it's not a studio we had
somebody come who thought it was an
actual studio they're like oh it's a
house
but uh but then when i get out there and
you know go to these conventions and
conferences i don't i'm just so
encouraged to see that the content is
helping you you know uh when people say
thank you it goes a long way for me like
because you know we make these videos a
kind of uh in an offense mentality like
whether you like it or not or putting
out this video type thing but just it's
good to know that it's being received
well and it's actually helping people
and so i would say that's one of my
favorite things and one of the coolest
things about being a full-time youtuber
what are you excited about for this next
uh phase in youtube as youtube's growing
as more people are becoming full-timers
i mean we actually we just heard from a
student today they just reached a
hundred thousand they are now full-time
100 000 subscribers they're now
full-time they're starting to grow a
team like we're seeing this happening in
our community on a weekly basis now what
are you excited about for the future of
youtube
i think i'm just more excited to see
it work for more people like because i
genuinely believe there's a space for
you on youtube and that there is a place
for you and that it's it's not too
crowded youtube has a way of making
uh the the the idea of it being crowded
like not be real because you see
everyday newcomers grow and thrive
they've just found their way of reaching
their audience in a new unconventional
way so i think it's more or less like uh
i i get excited seeing these newer
creators like orion seeing newer
creators or or even when when my life is
changing like i maybe want to buy a van
or an rv and so
wait can we pause there i'm so pumped
omar started watching vampires i know i
started
and then i stumble upon people who are
killing it it's just kind of cool it's
like it's like youtube is just the the
younger brother the older brother you
never had you know like it'll it'll be
there with the people that you need help
from uh for my future as whoever how i'm
going as a human being
but also the newcomers and the people
who just
somehow were able to hit a million
subscribers in a month like that's
exciting like to learn people who are
jumping in and still finding a huge
success so i i think i'm excited that
the opportunity of youtube is still wide
open yeah well thanks omar for uh so fun
we did it i did it we did it uh this is
the first of many times and where it's
gonna be thank you for inviting me on
your show heather you know i'm here for
all of the firsts you know
um but you share so much wisdom uh on a
weekly basis over on our think media
channel and you've been crushing the
reels right now omar over on your
instagram so make sure you follow omar
over on instagram uh if you want to see
not just omar but the cutest cutest
toddler ever because ruby ruby's a
content creator now as well she's the
secret to the brand yeah yeah so uh
thanks so much for being on thank you
well i hope that you got value out of
that conversation i always love having
the think fam here in the studio and on
the show wasn't that great to get to
hear a little bit more about omar's
story and you know just his secrets to
becoming a full-time youtuber and if you
want to see another featured content
creator here on the show let me know in
the comment section below if you are
watching on youtube and if you've not
yet rated and reviewed the podcast over
on apple itunes and you are an avid
listener over there i'm gonna encourage
you to go over and actually rate and
review the show it helps us see if we're
delivering the right content that you
like and it helps other content creators
know that they are in the right place
when they read those reviews today's
review comes from lori blue eyes and she
says awesome team to follow if you are
even entertaining the idea of creating a
youtube channel this is the podcast for
you such great information thanks laurie
for leaving that review i'm so grateful
for you being a part of our think media
family and i hope that today's episode
has brought you value and that you are
going to be on the path to becoming a
full-time youtuber thanks so much for
listening make sure you subscribe
wherever you're watching or listening on
and we'll catch you in the next episode
bye
[Music]
you